- By a show of hands, how
many people are voting?
How many people are excited
to vote for Hillary?
My name's Darren Sands, I'm
a reporter with BuzzFeed News
based in Washington DC,
and I cover politics.
We're here in Tallahassee, Florida
visiting Florida A&M University,
it's a historically black college.
I'm trying to see where they are
in terms of their decision-making.
Whether they're gonna vote
and try to get a good sense
of what turnout is gonna
be like come November 8th.
Meet up with right now is one of
Clinton's organizers on campus
and we got to see her interact
with this young student,
a freshman, and she was not
actually committed to vote
- I don't know who to vote for.
I'm not voting for Trump if
that's what you're asking.
- You can be a leader, and say hey,
I have a car, I'm a freshman as well,
pack five, ten people in
your car, y'all sit on laps.
- Yeah.
- It's a short drive.
- They see you, you know, the
more they're likely to vote,
cause now that's a reminder, like oh,
that's the voter registration lady.
You do care, you know
this is my university too,
and I care about the students as well.
- [Darren] We get a chance to meet
the up and coming Mayor of Tallahassee,
a young black Mayor by
the name of Andrew Gillum.
- And I'll tell you, at least
on the social media side,
you almost don't have to
do a pro-Hillary message
because there's so much anti-Trump.
- You think that affects
the enthusiasm that she has?
- I'm over the enthusiasm question.
- A lot of people are over it.
- I'm over it and where I am is that
this is a matter of our futures
and our children's futures.
As I have closed out many
of remarks to campuses
and to students with,
elections are choices.
That there's some perfect out there
is not the case.
I don't believe Obama was perfect,
but I do believe that his intentions
are consistent with my belief system.
- And we talked to a lot of older voters,
black voters, people who went to FAM,
and they recognize the students
aren't that excited about Hillary.
- Be honest with you, they are
not really feeling Hillary,
I mean that's the truth to it.
- I talked to a lot of the students
who weren't that excited
about Hillary Clinton
- I've been hearing that a
lot from the young people.
- Even though they don't
per se like Hillary
they're gonna vote for her.
- Trump scares me.
I just really wish the candidates
would have been stronger on both sides.
- Also at the tailgate we got
the most enormous turkey leg
that I have ever seen in my entire life.
We go to the President's barbecue
and we talk to about maybe ten students
who are at this table getting
ready to work the barbecue.
How would you describe the
mood of the student body
as it relates to the election
and to the candidates?
- I don't feel like anything
that we do at this point,
or any person you can vote for
is going to be transparent about
what exactly they're gonna
do while they're in office.
And I don't have faith
that whatever anybody says
that they're going to
do that they will do.
Honestly, I had faith in a candidate,
Bernie Sanders, but that
candidate's no longer there.
- You go to Howard, Morgan
State, anywhere you went
they were basically all about Bernie,
and that frustrated a lot of Democrats
because you know, Bernie
wasn't a Democrat. (laughing)
- We fought for this African
American thoughtfulness
for decades, so the least
we could do is vote.
It's about, you know who we're voting for
is gonna be the biggest thing,
but just holding them accountable I think
is gonna really make the most difference.
- I feel like we can't risk Trump winning,
so that's why I'm going to vote.
- If I don't vote, that's
me endorsing both candidates
everything, like in it's entirety.
I feel like my vote matters
because in all actuality it does.
- By a show of hands,
how many people have been canvassed
and been asked if you're voting
or if you've been registered to vote?
So they've been canvassing
pretty well on campus.
- Tirelessly.
- Democrats are kind of
very anxious that there's
gonna be a repeat of 2000.
I think the campaign and also the DNC
have taken that to heart.
They know that if they turn out the voters
that they need to do,
they can win the election.
So that's what makes
it a turnout election.
Overall, we learned that
on this particular campus,
no, voters are not that excited
about casting a ballot
for Hillary Clinton.
But they've all been
engaged by the campaign.
They pretty much all have been asked
if they're registered to vote.
They're registered to
vote and they're voting.
Not only do they want to
make their voices heard,
but they also want to make sure
that she can be held accountable
for changes that can be
made with racial injustice,
and that they don't
wanna actually disrespect
the idea that people fought
for the right to vote,
they died for the right to vote,
they protested, blood was shed,
and at FAM, that's something
that people don't take lightly.